fin del libre comercio entre el reino
unido y la unión europea- bajo las
reglas de la oms organización mundial
del comercio las importaciones de ambos
lados del canal enfrentarían a tarifas
85% de los productos alimenticios
europeos que lleguen al reino unido
estarían sujetos a tasas del 5 por
ciento recargando potencialmente a los
supermercados británicos un sobre costos
de unos tres mil millones de libras
esterlinas por su parte los autos
británicos enviados a la unión europea
enfrentarían tarifas de 10% por unos 5
mil 700 millones de libras esterlinas al
año la oficina de presupuestos y
responsabilidad del reino unido prevee
que dichas tarifas le costarían un 2%
del pib a europa perder el libre acceso
al mercado británico le costaría cerca
de 33 mil millones de euros de ventas
anuales con una caída del 10 por ciento
en exportaciones los negocios en ambas
partes se enfrentarían a más papeleo y
controles de aduanas reino unido ha
estado luchando para construir docenas
de nuevos parques de camiones de paso de
aduanas para evitar la congestión en los
puertos simulacros recientes en
dirección a francia antes
en filas interminables en los pasos
fronterizos hay preocupación por el
abastecimiento de medicinas hacia el
reino unido en medio de la pandemia
aunque las autoridades indican que la
llegada de vacunas no se verá
interrumpida el sector de servicios
británicos representa el 80 por ciento
de la economía del país incluidos los
servicios financieros con cerca del 7
por ciento del pib un break sheet sin
acuerdo impediría a las firmas
británicas servir a clientes europeos
muchas ya constituyeron filiales
europeas para mantener el acceso también
significaría que las flotas de pesca
europeas perderían acceso a las aguas
británicas y viceversa amenazando el ya
precario modo de vida de las comunidades
costeras de ambos lados para los
ciudadanos el libre movimiento se acaba
al final del proceso de transición con o
sin tratado los ciudadanos británicos
perderán su derecho a vivir y a trabajar
en la unión europea a menos que ya
residan allí antes del fin del 2020 una
salida caótica del reino unido- del
mercado único no es el fin nuevo tratado
podría ser negociado en cualquier
momento sin embargo muchos observadores
dicen que podrían pasar meses en 2021
antes
y reanudar los diálogos